so can you do a whirlwind
overview of uh your career
in mma leading up to this point with the
injuries and the undefeated record
and then what's next on the topic well i
i did my first
fight in uh as a blue belt and i've been
training for about a year and a half i
did nine uh judicial tournaments in ten
weekends or eight maybe eight
tournaments in ten weekends prior to my
first fight in uh
april 2006 um i got punched in the face
a whole bunch i didn't realize it was a
professional fight
and found that out like the day
beforehand that was great
thanks coach uh it was in atlantic city
where another place no one ever goes on
purpose so that wasn't great
i got into three actually three car
accidents
in the preceding 36 hours before the
fight
i had my car totaled um i wasn't driving
for any of them that was great
uh it was 2006. 2006. yeah and then i
got a blue belt uh yeah yeah i've been
training for about a year and a half
you blue belt you're getting i mean if
you haven't lived if you haven't gotten
punched in the face in
atlantic city that's true i mean i so
these are
i would a lot i would have loved to have
it happen for different reasons yeah but
uh
yeah well what's funny is that you know
i i remember you know getting punched in
the face a bunch trying to do inverted
guard
i won one round lost two rounds
definitely lost the fight
and you went for inverted sorry to
interrupt you went for inverted guard
like can you tell the story of that
fight
yeah sure it was three three-minute
rounds which is not a professional fight
length although i don't know if
professional fight lengths would have
been any better it's just more time to
get punched
uh but uh i found out part way through
it was like i remember walking back to
my corner in the first round i'm like
this guy can't hurt me
he's like yeah my corner was my friend
tom and then someone else and he's like
yeah
i would still encourage you to stop
blocking so many punches with your face
i'm like that's a good idea time i
appreciate that i'm gonna try that
um anyway uh i remember like i was not
you're not allowed to upkick so i'm like
great i was
i had no martial arts skills it really
at all but if i had anything at all it
was jujitsu it was very very little jiu
jitsu
uh but definitely no wrestling
definitely no striking like i was
basically a magnet for punches
so that was your time uh that was you
know roughnecking out in atlantic city
as we all do
once in a while can we fast forward to
when you're actually dominating the
world
as a black belt well actually because i
took a little bit of money that they're
like hey
we're paying like really okay stories
with ryan hall
well then i went to i went to the casino
i went to whatever like the tropicana
that was right there
the casino because that was a boardwalk
call and i'm like you know what man this
was this has been a not great not great
evening i'm gonna
this is i'm gonna win it back it's gonna
be great
15 minutes later they had all the money
that i had from the fight was gone
yeah i remember like walking out of the
casino super pissed
and like i don't know what i was
thinking like i'm not good at gambling
why
this was not going to make my night
better i just thought that there was
going to be some sort of cosmic
balancing and maybe it was the cosmic
balancing all at once for things i've
done
longer term though yeah the the
balancing
we'll see i hope so but to come so we're
all dead in the end though
that is true time will get us all yeah
so
well that was so that was the first one
and that was when i realized i'm
terrible at mma but i like it
i should just stop this until i one day
learn how to actually grapple much less
learn how to fight but i remember this
guy named dave kaplan who's the reason
my ears are all messed up
who was on the ultimate fighter and got
punched in the face and knocked out by
tom lawler who i'll always appreciate
for doing that
um but uh anyway uh dave or tom uh
i appreciate tom i appreciate dave too
david it was great dave was just a huge
bully and used to like
really not completely unmercifully but
relatively unmercifully beat the crap
out of me and uh
anyway uh the years look good so
appreciate that i tell people it's a
tumor that i got and i'm gonna if they
want in on our class action lawsuit with
atmc they should you know
send and send me an email but uh anyway
you're very financially savvy
very good no i just give the impression
dave basically said hey don't worry man
you're never going to be good at
mma and you're never going to beat it
grappling either but even if you are
good at grappling which
in my opinion you will never be you will
never be good at fighting and i said
dave if i do nothing else in my life i'm
going to keep training until i can make
you pay for that
and now that i can make him pay for that
really easily he doesn't train anymore
but i love dave dave's awesome he
actually won the singing beat what an
interesting dude
super interesting guy but anyway uh none
of the virginia like speaks couple
languages super interesting guys like
shockingly good at jeopardy too um not
that i'm any good but still shockingly
good at jeopardy
you